avec 27,6 % d'abstention au premier tour
on a battu hier effectivement un triste
record depuis le début de la vème
république jusqu'à présent c'était en
1969 lors de l'élection de georges
pompidou qu'on avait voté le moins en
france 22 % d'abstention au premier tout
en 69 donc quelles sont les raisons de
ce phénomène le sentiment qui s'est
révélée être une erreur que le premier
tour était déjà joué première hypothèse
ajoutez à cela les vacances scolaires
pour les principales d'académie du pays
le beau temps et un désintérêt
progressif pour la politique et vous
obtenez un cocktail à 27 6 %
d'abstention karine comazzi philippe
bons signaux tout a commencé par une
mauvaise coïncidence ce matin du premier
tour était aussi celui de l'ouverture de
la pêche aux carnassiers au bord de
l'hérault les lecteurs pêcheurs avaient
déjà tranché
le suspense est plus intéressant on va
plutôt dire à la pêche premier tour des
élections
ça sera pareil qu'il se soit sa sombre
qu'il se soit alors que les 16 candidats
partent à la pêche aux voix les lecteurs
se dispersent dans une campagne
enfin à la hauteur de ses attentes
préférant l' isolement à l'isoloir
l'autre hasard du calendrier ce sont les
vacanciers parisiens qui en ont fait les
frais je n'ai pas pu faire de
procurations puisque je venais voir pour
quatre jours des amis pendant au milieu
des vacances scolaires de la région
parisienne donc pas de billets d'avion
pas de billet de train pas de
réservation d'hôtels donc pas de
possibilité de faire de préparation donc
le choix entre ben je prends ces quatre
jours je viens au soleil où je vais dans
l'isoloir midi taux de participation
national 21 41 % sous le chêne pluri
centenaire de saint guilhem le désert
la température frôle les 20 degrés avec
un zeste de mauvaise conscience une
abstentionnistes se justifie quand on
change d'intérêt
on pense à plein de choses et on voit
jamais la carte d'électeur c'est pas en
période d'élection n'y pense pas quelque
chose à laquelle france 17h30
on parle de record d'abstention sur la
plage de palavas personne ne semble s'en
émouvoir
c'est pas moi ça veut faire peur c'est
plutôt à la classe politique qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas à même de proposer
des solutions ou citoyen je pense que
l'on peut voir dans l'abstentionnisme
une certaine révolte de la part des
électeurs oui la journée du 1er tour
s'achève dans l'insouciance des
performances 27,25 % les
abstentionnistes battent leur record à
19h personne encore ne savait qu'ils
allaient boire la tasse